i heard you were gonna play hedy lamarr
in an upcoming apple series and i've
heard that she's like one of the she's
one of the most fascinating people in
hollywood
a lot of people i think young people
today don't know who hedy lamarr was
and what a fascinating story uh this is
but i'm really glad you're playing this
part
thank you so much this is the part i'm
super excited to play
and we've been working on it with apple
and it's
super exciting uh hedy lamarr is
basically um
you know a figure that got lost and
forgotten in the pages of history
uh she was an immigrant a jewish
immigrant from austria that came to
america in the 30s
and she became one of the biggest
hollywood stars
but at the same time she was at this
amazing inventor
who wanted to help speaking about impact
wanted to help
uh america uh while
they were fighting in world war ii so
she
and another composer uh had
invented this secret system of
communication
which is now basically the wi-fi and
bluetooth is all
based on that she never she got the
recognition for the invention
only when she was 80. she had a very
very
interesting life story and i can't wait
to
tell it no it's really fascinating that
if someone
if if someone didn't know if i didn't
know this was real
i would have said oh they're making that
up
one of the biggest most beautiful
hollywood stars
was also a tony stark level inventor
totally and and then was never given
credit for it
until very very late in life if someone
pitched that story
you'd say oh come on that's ridiculous
and it's all real it's a true story i
can't
i can't wait to see it thank you so much